welcome to e3 2014 I'm max here with Tom
mcshay who just got to take an extended
look at the new Dragon Age game now Tom
I want to know about this game because I
know a lot of people they really like
dragon age origins and then dragon age 2
not so much so where does this game kind
of stack up is it more action slanted
like to or is it a return to sort of the
strategic elements of one well it has
the action combat which okay the first
one to I mean you can't get into fray
your site right there's the magic powers
and there's the attack power you can get
right in the action but then you can
also zoom it out and it has that
tactical like an overnight am and you
can directly i want the archer over here
I want the rogue vanishing behind the
big dude like you can do all that stuff
so it has its tactical all the time it's
just a matter of if the enemies are
weaker whatever you're gonna go there
and swing your club okay so they're
trying to like strike a balance between
the two different styles instead of
being so skewed to the actions yes it
looks it looks like it strikes a good
balance but so then what did you is what
you saw similar to what they showed in
the presentation or was it a completely
new era it was it was in the
presentation but it was bandaged we got
to see more of the dragon fight we got
to see more of just walking around this
this world is gorgeous they walked
around I didn't want them to even do
anything did they give you any sense of
scale well they did they did the whole
thing with like this section here is
bigger than all of worship but I don't I
it's like 200 dragon ages all mixed in I
I don't care I don't care about that but
look it's a good-sized world that has
interesting things to do and it looks
good which is more important to me than
like the raw square mileage who cares
and then dragon age of course has a ton
of memorable characters throughout the
series every seeing any returning
familiar face they said there be
returning familiar faces though there
was none of them so far but we saw just
one dude we had like a little evil
mustache it was it lacks was he doing
mom he's apparently a good guy but we
will see about that this is a weird game
for me because everything I saw looked
incredible sure like absolutely
incredible but like the second one kind
of sucked I know so the helpers
obviously they want to put their best
foot forward but how indicative of is
this
or enterprise yeah I know so I mean it's
it was a controlled demo for a half hour
it wasn't playable even though it comes
out october seven right but really i am
completely optimistic i think that game
works incredible and he already said
it's coming out october seven yeah bruh
which platforms i I mean I don't know if
its previous gen but it's I mean current
Jenna pc alrighty folks will of course
keep it locked to gamespot com for our
ongoing coverage of e3 2014